[Music]
this study of genetics is incomplete
without understanding the loss put forth
by Mendel after his experiments of mono
hybrid and dihybrid crosses Mendel
concluded that these are certain factors
which are passed from one generation to
the other but he explained this better
with the help of his first law in
genetics the first law in genetics is
called the law of segregation to
understand this law we first need to
understand the concept of alleles we
know that genes in simple terms are the
units of heredity that carried genetic
information alleles are nothing but the
different forms of genes let's take a
simple example to understand this assume
we have these two chromosomes here we
have jeans for the karaszia height can
you tell me which genes could possibly
be present here we can have either both
capital T T or both lowercase T T and we
can even have one capital and one
lowercase D T as the gene set now here
the individual T that is the single gene
is nothing but the allele so the
alternative form that is either dominant
or recessive is called allele in simple
words one single T or T is an allele now
that we know what alleles are let's try
to understand the law there are
different definitions you will find for
this law but let's pick the simplest one
it says that during gamete formation the
alleles for each gene segregate from
each other such that each gamete formed
carries only one allele for each gene it
mister sound a bit confusing to
understand this let's take a simple
example
let's assume we have the single cell
with only two chromosomes in it the
chromosomes have a set of genes CC for
the
skin color in an individual now to
understand the law let's break it into
parts the first part says during gamete
formation this is the process of meiosis
it is the type of cell division which
gives us four cells with half the number
of chromosomes the second part says the
alleles of each gene so here C and C is
what we're referring to that means one
allele from the gene set now what's the
next part the next part of the statement
is segregate from each other this means
the alleles will separate they will not
remain together in the process and now
comes the last part it says that one
gamete carries only one allele for each
gene now this part means that at the end
of the meiosis process we will get four
cells such that each cell will have only
one allele in it so here two cells will
have capital C and the other two cells
will have the lowercase C allele does
each gamete gets only one allele to
summarize we can say that the alleles
for a gene segregate during gamete
formation to be honest this loss sounds
very obvious to us now it's like having
a big book with many chapters in it and
then we make smaller books for each
chapter it is obvious that the smaller
books will have the content resembling
the content of the big book this law
sounds obvious also because we know the
process of meiosis but nobody knew this
back in the earlier times hence it was
hypothesized by Mendel and then it was
accepted as a law later so what's the
next law it's the law of independent
assortment does this mean that the genes
assort independently or is there
anything else that the law specifies
let's find that out in the next part
there is one common thing among thieves
dust particles and a dice roll on the
floor any guesses what that common thing
could be its randomness randomness is
commonly found in nature and in several
things around us but can you state an
example of randomness that occurs inside
us though our body seems to be organized
there are a few processes that have no
fixed pattern one of the processes is
that of the alignment of chromosomes on
the metaphase plate let me elaborate
imagines this to be a cell that's about
to undergo division for now let's assume
it's undergoing meiosis we note that
during cell division a stage named
metaphase is reached where the
chromosomes align themselves on the
equatorial plane in other words on the
metaphase plate so can you tell me how
these chromosomes will align before they
line up on the plate will all the red
chromosomes from each pair line up on
one side or will they align in an
alternate manner or maybe like this
or will the alignment be like this there
are numerous ways in which this can
happen and this is random there is no
fixed pattern or a principle of sequence
that the chromosomes follow when they
align now if the chromosomes get
separated randomly it's obvious that the
genes present on them will also get
separated randomly so let's say this
pair has the genes capital A and
lowercase a this pair has the gene set
capital B and lowercase B while this one
has capital C and lowercase C on it we
are considering all the sets to be
heterozygous in order to understand the
concept better so when the chromosomes
get separated in the respective cells
it's obvious that the genes will assort
independent of each
there is no thumb rule that all the
dominant alleles will perpetuate in one
cell and all the recessive alleles in
the other they can assort independent of
each other this is exactly what Mendel
had to say in his second law of genetics
it's named the law of independent
assortment the law says that genes for
the different traits assualt independent
of each other during gamete formation
let's understand this with the help of
this cell the first part says genes for
different traits this means we are
addressing the genes which represent
diverse traits so here we have the gene
sets' a a BB and CC on these respective
chromosomes these are the genes for
different traits now the second part
states are sort independent of each
other
this means the genes will not have a
fixed pattern to follow when they
segregate in the cells so here the
alleles of the gene set a a will assort
independent of the other two gene sets
it's not mandatory that all the dominant
alleles will get assorted in the cells
together so the allele capital a can get
assorted with any allele from the gene
set BB and CC and that's the reason why
we get the gametes with different
possible combinations at the end to
quickly review the assortment of alleles
is purely random and does not have a
predictable and fixed pattern during the
process of gamete formation that is what
the law says there can be more
possibilities of obtaining different
combinations depending upon how the
chromosomes align themselves on the
metaphase plate now tell me which type
of a cross will help us understand this
law better a monohybrid cross or a
dihybrid cross think about it let me
help you with this if it's a monohybrid
cross then there will be no independent
assault
of the different alleles and why is that
so that's because we are considering
only one character at a time so we will
be dealing with a single gene set and
does this law is best understood when
there are more than one character
studied at a time this is nothing but
the dihybrid cross or higher crosses
which involve more characters now that
we're well versed with the first two
laws of genetics let's have a look at
the third law in our upcoming part
a scene of lush green trees covered with
yellow or brown mesh is not new to us we
have come across it many times any idea
what this mesh is all about these are
also plants the parasitic plants to be
precise being parasitic they derive all
the nutrients from the host and grow to
form a huge structure these plants are
less Reapers and overpower the huge
trees as they grow this is one of the
best examples for understanding the fact
that dominance is not a matter of size
rather it's never affected by size it's
the nature of the dominating component
that matters let's take our genes for
example we know how small genes and the
Constituent alleles are yet there is one
form which dominates the other we are
familiar with the concept of dominant
genes and recessive genes but this
wasn't known back then not even to
recomendar that is the reason why he put
forth the concept of dominant and
recessive alleles with the help of this
law this law is called the law of
dominance
after the monohybrid cross mental
concluded that a few genes are dominant
while the others are recessive let's
have a look at what the law has to say
the third law of genetics known as the
law of dominance states that some Leafs
are dominant while others are recessive
an organism with at least one dominant
allele displays the effect irrespective
of the presence of the recessive one the
law is actually very simple let's take
an example and understand it let's
consider a cross of a tall and a dwarf
plant the first part of the law says
that some alleles are dominant while
others are recessive here can you tell
me why is this blonde tall that's
because it has both the dominant alleles
we
represented with the capital letters TT
similarly this is a dwarf plant as it
has both the recessive alleles denoted
by TT in the lowercase now the next part
of the law states that an organism with
at least one dominant allele displays
the effect irrespective of the presence
of the recessive one so what does that
mean here on crossing the two we get
these plants in the f1 generation the
phenotype of all these plants is tall
and what is their genotype as we can see
they are all heterozygous and with one
dominant and one recessive allele
doesn't the tall's phenotype clearly
indicate that the dominant allele has
masked the presence of the recessive one
that's right that's what the second part
of a law says the presence of a single
dominant allele is enough to express the
trait we know typically and what if both
the genes are dominant it's obvious that
the phenotype will be dominant the law
states at least one dominant allele
which means if one or even both the
alleles are dominant then we get the
respective dominant phenotype
now let's cross this f1 generation to
check whether we have understood the law
correctly the cross of these f1 hybrids
gives us these offsprings in the f2
generation can you help me with the
phenotype and the genotype of these
offsprings here we get three tall plants
and one dwarf plant genotypically
there is one plant that is homozygous
for the dominant trait there are two
plants which are heterozygous and this
last one is again homozygous but for the
recessive trait so can we relate these
results with our law of dominance there
are two types of alleles one dominant
and one recessive this is what the first
part says and the second part says that
at least one dominant allele displays
the effect
irrespective of the presence of the
recessive one so as we can see here that
these three plants are tall because they
contain the alleles T foot-tall trait
this one has both the dominant alleles
and these two have one allele for the
dominant trait
its present mosques or suppresses the
effect of the recessive allele so this
was about the third law of genetics
called the law of dominance
[Music]